this is a crazy story I thought this was
fake when I first heard about it Lauren
bobert is about to be a grandmother
now I know I know you're saying wait
Lauren bobert how old is she Lauren
bobert is 36 years old and she is about
to be a grandmother because her teenage
son is going to be having a baby next
month and listen there are a lot of
cultural differences between different
parts of the country there's no doubt
about that uh and it is much less common
in parts of the country more liberal
parts of the country uh to see something
like this celebrated and I'll tell you
why in a moment with some statistics but
Lauren bobert is celebrating it Lauren
bobert is acting like it's a good thing
that she as a former teen mom is now
going to be a grandmother thanks to her
son becoming a teen dad let's take a
look at this big announcement from
Lauren bober this is this is uh there's
a lot here okay I'm a mom of four boys
and I've said many times Jason and I we
are raising our four boys to be men okay
before liberals teach them to be women
okay
[Applause]
but I leaned over and I asked my husband
if it was appropriate to announce this
here today so I'm going to tell you all
for the first time in a public setting
that not only am I a mom of four boys
but come April
I will be a GG to a brand new a brand
new grandson
wow
even this crowd is sort of like okay
yeah kind of like a muted reaction I
have to say
[Applause]
now any of you who have young children
who are
giving life
there are some questions that pop up
there's some there are a hell of a lot
of questions popping up based on what
she's saying that's for sure fear that
arises
now my son when I approached him and
told him Tyler I'm going to be a 36 year
old grandmother
he said well didn't you make granny a 36
year old granny said yes I did right
he said well then it's hereditary
nice that's pretty interesting actually
there's actually a lot there and here's
an additional clip again where Lauren
bobert she talks about
she she talks about this like it's a
good thing okay and she wants to make it
a cultural thing she wants to talk about
how great is it that the culture of life
in red States leads to a high teen birth
rate and you know there's something
special about rural conservative
communities yes there is
they value life if you look at teen
pregnancy rates throughout the nation
well they're the same in rural and urban
areas however abortion rates are higher
in urban areas and Teen Mom rates are
higher in rural conservative areas
because we understand the preciousness
of the life that is about
to be born wow so a few different things
now I don't want to make this into a
cultural critique there is a cultural
critique here to be made without a doubt
okay but by their own claims by their
own claims it's not really clear to me
that these really are the pro-life
values as exhibited by
teens who get pregnant in red States not
seeking abortions I don't think that
that's the great thing to celebrate that
Lauren bobert is making it out to be
because the most important thing to look
at here
is how do the kids of teen parents do in
life
and the children of young mothers do
notably less well in life this is not
about saying Lauren bobert's grandkid
deserves to do poorly the grandkid I
would consider a victim in this
situation it's that the kid is not being
well set up to succeed when you look at
outcomes of all sorts and types poverty
How likely to graduate high school all
of these different things you see the
ideal outcomes when the parents or
usually what they're looking at is the
mother
is at least 25 years old and then from
20 to 25 year old moms you see less good
outcomes and then when the mom is under
20 you see absolutely the worst outcomes
and the the difference is significant
now this isn't about saying a 19 year
old can't be a good mom of course that's
not the case this isn't about saying if
you're 18 and you have a kid you love
the kid any less or whatever it is not
about that but the younger the mother is
the higher the rate of poverty the less
likely the child is to graduate high
school you get the picture but then we
get not only to the weirdness of
celebrating this when we know that
statistically it's actually not a good
thing the hypocrisy here is that the way
to prevent this if you think it's not a
good thing now Lauren bobert seems to be
celebrating it okay there is a cultural
aspect of this if you think this isn't a
good thing
the way to prevent it is of course safe
legal access to abortion we know that
but teaching comprehensive sex education
that reduces teen pregnancy it's been
studied widely comprehensive sex ed
reduces teen pregnancy Lauren bobert is
against that Lauren bobert recently
voted against funding that and so there
is that aspect to it as well which is
she is partially to blame certainly her
movement is to blame for the creation of
the circumstances that got us here in
the first place and by the way Lauren
bobert also says that children should be
forced to wait until they're age 21 to
make decisions about just even what
their gender expression is going to be
but having a baby at 17 is a great thing
and is fine that's also another one of
these stunning hypocrisies so listen
there when we talk about different
different American cultures
um this is one aspect that is very very
different and to what degree some of
what she's doing is a rationalization
because the cake is baked for lack of a
better term I don't know
uh but it is really really wacky stuff
if you want to see Lauren bobert deliver
this news to this titillated crowd all
of these clips that I played will be on
our Instagram which you can find by
searching Instagram for David Pacman
show
I like wine but I know very little about
it and I am completely clueless when I
go to a wine shop I just don't know what
I'm looking for I don't know what I'm
looking at I couldn't tell you anything
about varietals or if there's hints of
Persimmon or any of it and so if you're
like me wishing you had a seasoned
expert by your side when you're choosing
wine crunchy red fruit is the answer
crunchy red fruit delivers Choice
handcrafted small production wines right
to your door every bottle is hand-picked
by owner and master sommelier Jackson
rohrba in Seattle and comes with food
pairing suggestions we've been chatting
with Jackson his curating puts an
emphasis on organic low intervention
wines wines without artificial yeasts or
chemicals crunchy red fruit sources from
small scale sustainable Vineyards and
only wines that are true to their
location and grape crunchy red fruits
bi-monthly wine club is called the
circle every two months you'll get three
or six bottles to enjoy with videos to
help you appreciate what you're drinking
go to crunchyredfruit.com use the code
Pacman for twenty dollars off a single
purchase or if you join their bi-monthly
wine club send a message to circle
crunchyredfruit.com after you sign up
and they'll take twenty dollars off your
first shipment the link is down below